pourrait pas qu'on laisse penser que les
forces de l'ordre ont tué ined redouane
parce que c'est faux pas aussi il faut
que ça à en croire la contre expertise
menée par le site d'investigation
disclose et le cabinet forensic
architecture l' enquête démontre que la
responsabilité de la police est plus que
jamais engagée c'était il ya tout juste
deux ans le 1er décembre 2018 lors d'une
manifestation de gilet jaune à marseille
zineb redouane 80 ans est touché par une
grenade de gaz lacrymogène alors qu'elle
refermer les volets de son appartement
situé au 4e étage
grièvement blessé au visage elle décède
le lendemain à l'hôpital
et très vite la police est pointé du
doigt
quel traumatisme généré avec des photos
qu'on a vu de la mer les et doux c'est
très souvent c'est pour ça qu'on veut
que justice soit faite rapidement la
justice bafouille dans les premiers
temps et après de nombreux couacs la
sphère est dépaysé à lyon en août 2019
suite à des soupçons de collusion entre
le parquet de marseille et les policiers
mis en cause sur les cinq policiers
porteurs d'un lance grenade au moment
des faits aucun n'a reconnu son
implication et en mai 2020 un rapport
balistique remis à la justice comprenant
l'analyse de vidéos de surveillance par
exemple disculpait la police larmes a
été utilisé selon les préconisations les
procédures d'emploi en vigueur dans la
police nationale
sauf qu'une reconstitution vidéo de la
scène a réalisé par dix chloé forensic
architecture démontrerait aujourd'hui le
contraire le policier aurait utilisé son
arme un lance grenade de type cougar de
manière non réglementaire selon le texte
encadrant usage de cet équipement
le tir tendu est strictement interdite
afin d'éviter que les personnes ne
soient directement impactés autrement
dit le tir doit suivre une trajectoire
parabolique dit en cloche et le document
de préciser il incombe aux porteurs de
larmes d'apprécier la trajectoire de la
grenade et d'envisager le point
d'explosion ou d'impact pourtant depuis
sa position et en adoptant un angle de
tir compris entre 30 et 45 degrés le
policier dirige forcément son arme vers
la façade d'un des immeubles situés
devant lui une dizaine de fenêtres se
trouve potentiellement sur la
trajectoire de sa grenade un tir non
adaptés et dangereux
fatal à zineb red one qui succombent de
ses blessures le lendemain
dans les faits le projectile a heurté la
partie supérieure du corps de zineb
redouane au bout de 37 m l' expertise
balistique précise que l'impact a eu
lieu dans la phase encore montante de la
trajectoire à une vitesse de 97,2 km
heure
la violence du choc a provoqué un fracas
de l'ensemble de la partie droite du
visage de l'octogénaire la victime a
également inhalé une très grande
quantité de gaz lacrymogènes la grenade
mp7 est temps prévu pour évacuer un
espace extérieur d'environ 1000 mètres
carrés
au lendemain de la publication de cette
contre-enquête la famille annonce porter
plainte devant la cour de justice de la
république contre christophe castaner
pour altération et soustraction de
preuves
le ministre de l'intérieur de l'époque
avait déclaré que la victime était morte
d'un choc opératoire et non d'un choc
faciale et carton donc toute
responsabilité des crs